well the story is likely to come very
quickly back to the UK because when the
brexit deal comes before Parliament
every vote counts and Teresa may might
find that her fate lies in the hands of
a small band of Labour MPs one of them
is Lisa Danbury so let's talk to Lisa
Nandi who joins us live now so the big
question I suppose is we've now got that
endorsement from the EU leaders is the
deal on the table something that you
will be supporting well I've hopes that
it would be but in all honesty no it's
not and it's inconceivable now that when
this comes before Parliament in just a
few days time that I'll be voting for it
I won't be voting to support the
withdrawal agreement the problem isn't
the withdrawal agreement itself it's
this 26-page political declaration that
comes alongside it which still even just
with a few days to go until this crunch
vote offers no guide as to what the
future holds for the UK the problem
that's facing someone like me sitting
here in Wigan is that I don't know at
all from that 26 page declaration
whether the future of the UK looks like
one that is very closely allied to the
EU with all of the standards at work and
protections that come with it or whether
we're going down a low tax low wage
economy that will remove all of those
rights that work that my constituents
rely on just down the road I've got
people who work in factories on the
railways and in the construction
industry and this is not an academic
question for them these are health and
safety laws for example that have kept
people alive at work in Wigan for
decades because of those EU regulations
that we ourselves have negotiated and as
a consequence we've got a few days to go
we've got 26 pages of virtually nothing
about what the future holds there's been
no attempt to reach out to Labour MPs
like me I haven't had a single phone
call from the other side as well as very
little attempt to talk to the front
bench or to the trade unions either and
it's just too big a gamble for MPs like
me to take with our constituents futures
you say that it's too big a gamble to
take but of course No Deal would be a
huge gamble as well for your
constituents - you've said previously
that it would be a disaster so is it
really responsible to risk No Deal by
not back in the deal well this is the
thing that is keeping MPs awake at night
it's been suggested that it would be
difficult for MPs like me to vote
against this deal because many of our
constituents voted to leave but the
truth is it's those thousands of jobs in
food manufacturing just down the road
from here that are keeping me awake not
my own job instead and there is a real
prospect now of No Deal because many of
those leve voters contrary to the
opinion in Westminster actually dislike
this deal more than the remain voters
who contact me on a regular basis they
that position has hardened over the last
six months whereas six months ago people
were saying to me we should leave and as
long as we leave I don't mind what form
that takes now leave voters in Wigan
often contacting me including a man who
I spoke to yesterday who said I've
changed my mind
I just want no ties at all with the EU
so this is a very real prospect and
there's a problem coming down the line
because potentially we're about to vote
down all of the alternatives to this
agreement in Parliament and then we're
going to vote down the agreement itself
and there is a complacency from a number
of MPs I heard it from James broken
share just now on your program I've
heard it from amber rod that says that
Parliament will resolve this but
Parliament has shown itself unable to
resolve this and that's why we need a
reset and a completely different
approach you say we need a reset in a
completely different approach but what
does that actually mean I mean how does
do you break through this impasse
because I have to say speaking to you
you say you can't bake for the deal if
Labour MP is like you can't support it
then there's no chance of her getting it
through the console
well the reason that Parliament is
divided is because the public is divided
we've had two and a half years that have
essentially entrenched those divisions
in the country and the only way that a
with rural agreement will pass
Parliament it's becoming increasingly
clear is if we have some clarity about
what the future looks like in Ireland
for example they view citizens
assemblies to try and break that
deadlock and make recommendations to
Parliament but that would require Teresa
May to go back to the EU and ask for
more time in order to establish that
process of dialogue because the truth is
that I represent a lot of people in
Wigan who voted to leave but I also have
many constituents like all of my
colleagues who voted to remain and we
will not settle this through a tug of
war people have to feel that they have a
stake in their future if I were to
resume what I would be doing now is
accepting that this withdrawal agreement
is not going to pass until we've had
that process of dialogue until we've
given the public and Parliament a real
say in what comes next
taken some of the heat out of this
debate and shed more light on what
should happen next instead that will
mean delay delay has a cost I accept
that but we have to be honest with
people now that there is no option on
the table that doesn't have a cost I'm
sitting here in Wigan where 30 years ago
the Thatcher government decided to close
the mines and we're still dealing with
the fallout of that decision now I don't
want to be sitting here in 30 years
saying to you we made the wrong decision
we didn't take the time to get it right
and as a consequence we're dealing with
the fallout again what does the delay
mean are you calling for an extension to
article 50 so that more negotiation can
happen I'm calling for a delay to
article an extension of article 50 not
so that more negotiation can happen
within the Conservative Party which is
what we've seen over the last three
years two wings of the Conservative
Party negotiating whether we have a hard
grexit or a harder brexit and call not
asking for more negotiation between the
EU and between the UK because I think
their withdrawal agreement largely does
what it's set out to do but that
negotiation
in the country has simply not happened
and I've stood in Parliament over the
last three years and listened to
colleagues accusing one another of
betrayal trying to call for alternatives
like a people's vote so that the result
of the referee referendum can be
overturned but we won't settle this
through a tug-of-war and we won't settle
it through the angry rhetoric that we've
had over the last few years that's why
we need a process of dialogue and
consensus in truth she should have done
this three years ago
and there were people like me but many
other bigger voices like Gordon Brown as
well calling for that we've wasted a lot
of time but we need to take the time to
get this right
and I appreciate that many people in
this country are desperate for us to
move on and try to look at the issues
that really matter like mental health
like Social Care all of which matter
more to my constituents actually than
this ongoing desperate debate about the
EU but if we don't get this right we're
not going to resolve it and we will
still be talking about it in ten years
time and that's why I say she has to go
back extend article 50 and start that
process with the country that she should
have done three years ago okay we'll
leave it with that cheery thought that
we'll still be talking about this at ten
years time at least Mandy thank you very
much